I love him.
But I'm telling you...
So Tim - sourdough - very
fashionable, everyone loves it.
What makes a perfect
starter, and what's
the best way to look
after it and get it going?
Well, you start off with
some flour, preferably,
if you can get it, some
sort of unbleached flour,
so it's still got some
natural yeast in it.
You add an equal amount
of water to that,
and you leave it
standing around.
You can speed that
process up by putting
in a handful of
dried fruit, and it
will collect the
yeasts in the air
and start a sourdough
culture moving.
And after a couple
of days, it will
start to bubble a little bit,
and that's your starting point.
You feed it with an equal
amount of flour and water.
Each time I want to feed
it, I pour away most of it.
50 to 100 grammes
left in the bottom.
And then to that I add
roughly 200 grammes of flour,
200 grammes of water
every time I feed it.
And it's one of those things
that works really well
if you've been doing
it all your life.
Which I haven't been doing.
I've had mixed results
with my starters.
There's this one, which was
last fed about two days ago,
I think, three days ago which
I almost poured on my laptop.
In fact, I did just
pour on the laptop.
That's a good start.
That's the one that's
been fed more recently.
It's actually been bubbling
over like a magic potion.
The simplest thing that we
could do with it, I thought,
would be pizzas.
Takes away all the
fuss about trying
to shape the loaf,
which is so complicated.
So get yourself a bowl.
I'm going to use a mixture of
strong flour and plain flour.
They've run out everywhere.
So I went straight
to the bakery.
They only sell it
in 16-kilo sacks.
So I've been distributing to
all of my friends and family,
anyone who needs it.
How much did you pay for it?
£15 for 16 kilos.
So that is a really, really
decent, generous baker
you've got there.
If he tries to sell
it to you for 60 quid
You probably could sell it
for 60 quid at the moment.
So we'll put in 150 grammes
of strong flour, 150 of plain,
10 grammes of salt, 50
grammes of olive oil.
Pour in 200 grammes
of your starter.
You say "pour."
I wonder where
the spoon might...
Spoon is fine.
Well, it's like looking
alive, which of course, it is.
So what should
that take it up to?
My maths is terrible.
Zero it every time.
Oh, God, I haven't done that.
So you'd have been on 360.
OK, so I need to
get it up to 460?
560.
And the last thing
you're going to need
is going to be 150
grammes of water.
Zero it every time, of
course you should do that.
I love him, but
I'm telling you...
Use a fork, or
something like that,
to just really, really
loosely mix that together.
And then let it sit
for about half an hour.
Just knead it until
it's good and elastic,
and we can come
back to it later.
Take your clove of garlic.
Cut it across the middle.
Empty the garlicky
bits out of the top
and put them straight into the
bottom of your roasting tin.
Pour in two cans
of tomatoes on top.
You add pepper and salt to that,
and a squidge of olive oil.
Just give it a
really loose stir.
My granddad used to always
put sugar in his tomato sauce.
Where do you stand on that?
You shouldn't need it
with decent tomato.
His tomato sauce was great.
What you can do is a
shot of balsamic vinegar.
It also adds a
little bit of sour.
So then just chuck
the lot in the oven.
That's so simple.
I don't think I'm never going to
make a tomato sauce on the hob
again.
That's it.
Mine looks a little
black around the edges.
Should I be worried about that?
That's fine.
Scrape it in.
Yeah.
All of your garlic should
have gone completely flat,
so you should be able to do
this by mashing with a spoon.
This sauce is the absolute
New York pizzeria.
It's like an American standard
because you can do it really,
really quickly by putting the
sauce ingredients in the pizza
oven.
It's a good, old school sort
of catering industry trick.
That's it.
That's the sauce.
All of our sourdough
cultures are different,
so they work at different rates.
So the rule that we tend to
use is, has it doubled in size?
Now once yours has doubled
in size, it's done its thing.
And then you need to
cut it into four pieces
and form each of those
pieces into a neat ball.
You don't have to
worry about keeping
everything tight and neat
doing the shaping bit.
Just make them
roughly into balls,
and then stack them
up in a tray and put
that tray in the fridge.
In the industry, we
call this retarding.
We're going to retard
the dough overnight,
and that's going to give
it a time to develop better
flavours.
Put some flour on the table.
Pick up one of your balls.
Place it in the
middle of the flour.
Allow it to use its own
weight to kind of stretch out,
by passing it from
finger to finger.
And as soon as you start to
get a sort of round shape,
put it down on the flour.
Pull it out sideways
with your fingers.
You've got it.
That's good.
That's really good.
It doesn't take
much more than that.
Now if you were
an Italian, you'd
now throw IT up in
the air and catch it.
If you get a tear in it,
you can squeeze it close.
Have you got a peel?
A peel?
One of those things for shooting
a pizza onto a pizza stone.
Oh, yeah, a big shovel thing?
Go get your big shovel thing.
It's way too big
for our kitchen.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
Wait until you see this.
It's perfect.
That's a commercial one.
Yes.
I'm using a circular tin tray.
Put some flour on the peel
and then put the pizza dough
on top of it.
And then sort of
shuggle it about,
just to make sure that
it moves on the peel.
So I've got a pizza stone,
which, of course, heats
the pizza up to a much
higher temperature
than my oven would do otherwise.
Can you do these kind of
pizzas just in a regular oven?
Totally.
The thinner the
steel tray you use,
if you're putting
it on an oven tray,
the better, because that
will heat through quicker.
Oh, OK.
Continuing to stretch it just a
little bit around the outside,
leaving a slightly raised
crust, and now mine's
perfectly circular, and
I'm very happy with it.
Don't put heavy
downward pressure on it.
Because that way you'll
probably tear the base,
which we don't want to do.
Use a maximum of two
tablespoons full.
Now sprinkle of
black pepper on top.
Cheap stick-block mozzarella.
That seems to be difficult
to get at the moment,
so I got this off-brand burrata.
Tear it into little pieces
and drop them quite carefully.
I've got some particularly
fine olive oil floating about -
a little squirt of
that on top of it.
A fresh basil leaf can go
on top of there, as well.
Let's give it a little shuggle.
It's moving.
Do not take it to the oven
until you're absolutely
positive you can shoot it off.
Ah!
It almost slid off the shovel.
OK, let's put them in the oven.
Ah, there she goes.
Yeah, that shouldn't take too
long, right - five minutes,
or something?
If that.
Tim, where do you stand
on pizza toppings?
I always got the
sense that the purists
think that just
cheese and tomato is
how you judge whether a pizza
is a really good quality.
TIM HAYWARD: I think
now we're in lockdown,
we need to stop being
so damn judgmental.
There's a lot to be said
for a good Neapolitan
pizza, which is very pure,
close to what we're making here.
But - and if you tell
anybody I've said this,
I will come to your
house and I will kill you
and all those you love -
but I like ham and pineapple
on a pizza.
Ooh, scandal.
Sorry, my daughter's just
asked if she can be adopted.
OK, let's do it.
Oh, mate, that's really good.
I love your edges.
Look, I'm just going
to lift mine up.
Very nice.
Let's cut.
What you reckon?
That's pretty good.
You should to be
able to think now
of tweaks you could do to
that, because sourdough
goes so well with blue cheese,
or some slices of pear.
You don't have to
stick to just Italian.
Lahmacun is a Turkish flatbread.
Make the base that same way,
put olive oil all over it.
Then you crumble seasoned
ground lamb over the top of it.
Bit Of cumin, some
sumac, things like that
- bit of zaatar if you have it.
When it comes out, you put dots
of cream cheese on top of it,
or it can work with
feta, if you want to.
So there's so many
different ways
you can do it without having to
go through the whole routine of
- I'm really bored of
making sourdough loaves now.
I've made 12 bigger
than my head.
I don't want to do anymore.
The base is everything, and you
can taste the sour in the base.
You can taste that that's
sourdough pizza for sure.